welcome resumes per pack today we're
gonna play a quick sculpt sama later cuz
that's the thing I'm pretty notoriously
famous for being a great quickscoper on
the Internet's please do not play this
game if you are prone to epilepsy all
copyright materials belong to their
respective goddamnit this might mean
that I will oh wow haha what it has a
menu smooth sensitive oh damn up that
[ __ ] difficulty trihard insane I'll go
with trihard thank you rust
Shrek's da club oh god what the okay
yeah use the mouse to point and fire
enemies after 15400 and killstreak used
two buttons and this game is decided to
play it at 60fps oh wow
Oh quick scope it by the way kicks there
you go oh my god is that shrek shrek oh
oh oh
Getrag now yeah oh gosh slender no don't
oh a lemon ah de got me [ __ ] oh my god
alright let's try this again
I want to get a kill streak I want to
get a sweet ass [ __ ] kill streak get
rig surprise [ __ ]
quick scope was killed from knife
goodnight sweet prince
I can't keep up with foot sure legend
never dies
okay that's up to sensitivity and down
the difficulty I'm a camper now explain
the club how is this the club
oh no let me a pink no sorry I love this
subscribe sensuous oh my god oh my god
glad glad oh my god that looks like oh
my god I god oh yeah uh no I wish I
recorded that one I mean I gotta say
this is probably the most accurate
noscope simulator I've seen after the
cold dudes oh oh I think that was my
sample I can't fake is ready
I got a care package [ __ ] yeah what do I
get
what is this [ __ ] the Pokemon just okay
Oh son oh damn get rekt get Rago Oh
simionescu oh whoa oh this is not a good
what don't Oh God
[ __ ] it eliminated man okay that was
a great [ __ ] history I'm actually
enjoying this game what the [ __ ]
oh damn surveillance but I'm gonna get
so much [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
got another care package fantastic what
do I get this time pokeball what the
okay alright I haven't played call of
dudes for a while maybe this is some new
collab what a [ __ ] do I know
fantastic alright [ __ ] that
that was a can't even type my high score
is the [ __ ] boy I can choose
particles minecraft mine could mine
Koosh [ __ ] love my gosh
not just really stepped up a notch with
the graphics mine oh god that's a great
sample so [ __ ] ammo [ __ ] day oh oh
my love has been [ __ ] empty and
pointless until this point noscope
dullness [ __ ] mine crackers and I
wish I was optic oh damn oh damn I film
that [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I've gotta be optic
[ __ ] god oh man who is Bri I
can't wait anyway did so much [ __ ] so
how much [ __ ]
although sponsors I can't handle this
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is bonus mode got to
go so fast what did I [ __ ]
he's so fast but not facing them away
snicker oh god that's much as I can hand
over that [ __ ] I have a lot of [ __ ]
maps fish yeah that's great oh my god
does it really have AI i cant noscope
them though this is some oh man this is
cod this is called how do i get a Nuke
chick cat package
yeah package give me new cuckoo cuckoo
cuckoo oh god dammit cherry sword
all right choice I go go cheering whoa
cherry saw you're the best so much MLG
in disguise
I'm so [ __ ] good get rekt mother
[ __ ] Jesus Christ I understand the
epilepsy warning now [ __ ] time for
another care package
come on nuyk nuyk nuyk nuyk yes doggy
no scums so buddy - go
oh my god I gotta do I got a [ __ ]
noob um um mom oh they didn't kill
anyone with a [ __ ] yeah that's enough of
that game that is [ __ ] hilarious
Jesus Christ someone actually made this
moist cluttered ah thank you thank you
so much
great game I'll leave it down link in
description go ahead and like me you're
watching it's this guy come read today I
see Bruce the next one a blast